>>> INHE MIDDLE OF THIS
RUSSIAN INVASION OF UKRAINE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN DELIVERS HIS
FIRST STATE OF THE UNION
ADDRESS, CLEARLY IT HAS TO BE
WEIGHING ON HIS MIND AS HE
SYMPATHY HES TO CONGRESS AND THE
NATION TONIGHT.
JOINING US NOW, CNN SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST JOHN AVLON,
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "LINCOLN
AND THE FIGHT FOR PEACE," EVEN
MORE RELEVANT WITH PEACE AND
DEMOCRACY HANGING IN THE BALANCE
RIGHT NOW IN EUROPE.
JOHN, PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS TO
GIVE A SPEECH TONIGHT, WHICH
ISN'T THE ONE HE EXPECTED TO
GIVE A MONTH AGO.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE SPEECHES ARE WORKED ON FOR
MONTHS.
RARELY HAVE YOU HAD A STATE OF
THE UNION WITH A SENSE OF REAL
TIME HIGH DRAMA, OF AN
INTERNATIONAL CRISIS UNFOLDING,
THE U.S. AND U.S. PRESIDENT
MARSHALLING A COALITION TO
DEFEND DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS ONE OF BIDEN'S CORE
THEME FOR YEARS.
THIS SAY PROVING GROUND.
IN A TIME WHERE HE FACED A LOT
OF HEAD WINDS FROM POPULARITY, A
LOT OF CRITICISMS, YOU KNOW,
HE'S GOTTEN CREDIT EVEN FROM
PEOPLE LIKE FORMER SECRETARY OF
STATE CONDOLEEZZA RICE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN HELPING BOLSTER
THIS BROAD COALITION.
IT IS A MOMENT OF HIGH DRAMA
TONIGHT.
NOT YOUR TYPICAL STATE OF THE
UNION.
>> IF FREEDOM IS AT STAKE, WHICH
IT IS, IN UKRAINE, AND WE SEE IT
FROM VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY,
FREEDOM IS AT STAKE THERE,
YOU'VE WRITTEN SPEECHES BEFORE,
HOW DO YOU GO FROM FREEDOM IS AT
STAKE IN THE WORLD TO I'VE GOT
MONEY TO PAY FOR BRIDGES AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
I DON'T SEASON TO BE GLIB HERE,
HOW DO YOU THREAD THAT LINE?
DO YOU BOTHER TOUTING
ACHIEVEMENTS AND TALKING
DOMESTIC AGENDA OR SPEAK TO THE
BIG SUBJECT AT HAND.
>> YOU DO, BUT YOU DO IT IN THE
BACK HALF AND HERE IS HOW YOU DO
IT.
PART OF DEFENDING DEMOCRACY
ABROAD IS SHOWING IT CAN WORK AT
HOME.
MY FELLOW AMERICANS, MY FELLOW
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, WE NEED TO
SHOW THAT WE CAN DELIVER AND
HERE'S WHAT WE HAVE DONE AND
HERE'S WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
BECAUSE YOU NEED TO -- LOOK, HE
CAN TAKE ALL THE CREDIT IN THE
WORLD, AND THERE WILL BE A
LITTLE BIT AND THERE SHOULD BE
ABOUT THE PROGRESS MADE, 6
MILLION NEW JOBS, LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT, BUT PEOPLE ARE
FEELING THE PAIN OF INFLATION,
THE PAIN OF GAS PRICES, WHICH
COULD GO UP AS A RESULT OF THIS
CONFLICT.
HE HAS TO SHOW EMPATHY FOR THAT
AND A PLAN TO ADDRESS NOT JUST
FEELINGS OF EMPATHY.
THE AUDIENCE, NOT JUST CONGRESS,
NOT JUST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
BUT REALLY TRULY THE WORLD, SO
WHAT ASK HE SAY TO THE PEOPLE IN
UKRAINE AND WHAT DOES HE SAY TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
>> HE SAYS TO THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE, YOU ARE NOT ALONE, HE
ADDS EVEN MORE URGE NCY TO THIS
IDEA OF STANDING TOGETHER.
THIS IS THE PROVING GROUND.
PUTIN HAS REMINDED PEOPLE OF
THEIR RELEVANCE, OF THEIR
URGENCY, HE SOLIDIFIED THE
RESOLVE.
AMERICAN LEADERSHIP MATTERS.
TO PUTIN HE NEEDS TO STAND UP
AND SIMPLY SAY, WE REFUSE TO
LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE MIGHT
MAKES RIGHT.
AND WE WILL STAND UP TO BULLIES.
WE WILL STAND UP FOR DEMOCRACY.
AND THERE IS A LINE THERE
BECAUSE HE'S NOT -- HE'S NOT
GOING TO RISK GETTING IN A HOT
WAR.
THIS IS A REALLY DRAMATIC MOMENT
TO HIGHLIGHT THE BASIC
DIFFERENCE OF HIS VISION AND HIS
PRESIDENCY, CERTAINLY WITH HIS
PREDECESSOR, BUT HE HAS TO PIVOT
TO DOMESTIC ISSUES A